bonsoir Vincent Delile plaisir de vous
retrouver vous êtes à la caisse
maintenant à la Caisse de dépôt pour
analyser un peu cette décision de la
Réserve fédérale comment vous
interprétez le message de la Fed
aujourd'hui qui était interprété de
toute sorte de façon d'ailleurs sur les
marchés
en préambule la volatilité aujourd'hui
reflète que les investisseurs avaient
quelque peu espoirs que le message la
résa fédéral serait plus plus conciliant
on le vu la hausse des taux d'intérêt
cette année elle a été très rapide très
musclé on se retrouve au plus haut taux
de directeur depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est arrivé très très vite
alors ce que je retiens d'aujourd'hui
c'est que les taux n'ont pas fini de
monter
la fait la réserve se montre quand même
conscient du fait que il y a des effets
retardataires à ces hausses de taux
d'intérêt là donc faudra être à l'affût
de tout cela mais que les taux vont être
plus élevés et que c'est pas la fin de
ce cycle resservice c'est pas
et est-ce qu'on s'en va en récession aux
États-Unis donc
les premiers livres récession ont
beaucoup augmenté dans les dans les
derniers mois
lorsqu'on a des hausses de taux aussi
rapides ça amène un frein frein aux
dépenses de consommation qu'on commence
à percevoir aux États-Unis cependant on
n'a pas encore vu l'effet sur les le
marché de l'emploi la statistique
d'emploi est probablement le meilleur
baromètre et c'est le baromètre que la
Réserve fédérale va surveiller quand
l'emploi va se modérer va se tempérer
les gens de la fête vont se dire ok on
est peut-être allé trop loin cela dit un
indicateur que vous regardez de près et
vous nous avez apporté un graphique pour
montrer l'écart entre les taux d'intérêt
disant et les taux d'intérêt de deux ans
quand il y a un resserrement de l'écart
comme on voit présentement puis vous
allez nous le décrire un peu le
graphique pour nous aider à le
comprendre généralement ça précède une
récession absolument mais ce qu'on voit
l'écran c'est la différence entre les
taux d'intérêt de la Banque centrale
tous les terrains court terme et les
taux d'intérêt long terme il y a
plusieurs indicateurs précurseurs qui
sont très utiles lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
gère des portefeuilles est-ce qu'on
investit celui-ci a un taux de succès
assez élevé alors ce qu'on peut voir sur
le graphique c'est que les taux
d'intérêts ont tellement augmenté le
trou de la Réserve fédérale américaine
qui les plus élevé que les taux les taux
de marché donc ça c'est ça nécessite pas
les banques à prêter et le crédit à la
consommation la demande de prêt en est
affecté alors quand on regarde les
récessions historiques habituellement
c'est arrivé lorsque la ligne était dans
le négatif ici donc quand on voit ici la
baie s'il y a eu récession ensuite et
même chose ça c'est 2008 il y a eu
récession ensuite et là on est là on est
on est là il faut pour comprendre que
pour les réserves fédérale américaine
comme pour la Banque du Canada on essaie
de on essaie de colmater de mater
l'inflation on augmente les taux
d'intérêt on le voyait dans le discours
de Monsieur pavot on voit le savoir
lorsque l'inflation lorsque l'économie
va réagir à ses hausse de taux d'intérêt
là et c'est ce que la fête de faire pour
2023 se garder l'ouverture de ralentir
le tempo c'est important aussi dans le
discours de Monsieur Paol aujourd'hui le
thème les hausses de taux se poursuivent
mais le tempo va ralentir parce qu'à
coups de Sonic 15 points de base point
Sonic 15 ça va vite il faut s'attendre à
ce que ça ralentisse dans les prochains
mois donc une hausse qui va au-delà du
taux neutre c'est quoi le taux neutre le
taux neutre évolue beaucoup alors il y a
pas de on peut pas le voir avec
précision on parle de trois trois et
demi pour ça pour la raison fédérale le
tourneuse c'est le taux qui est ni
restrictif ni expansionniste alors si on
regarde les 10 dernières années on a eu
des taux d'intérêt à 1 à 0 l'an dernier
à deux pour cent ça c'était en la zone
très expansionniste trois et demi 4% on
est plus respectif et ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'y est pas retourné donc là
Monsieur Paolo nous dit aujourd'hui on
est conscient qu'on devient restrictif
on est à l'affût le tempo va ralentir
mais on n'a pas terminé notre travail la
banque
[Musique]
faut s'attendre à quoi sur les marchés
boursiers qui ont fortement fluctué
aujourd'hui oui elle est habituellement
lorsque les hausses de taux cessent
lorsque c'est terminé pour le récemment
monétaire on est à ralentissement
économique profond alors là alors ce qui
risque d'arriver c'est encore de la
volatilité parce qu'ils investisseurs
préférés que les hausses de Tours
ralentissent mais l'inflation est encore
là on le voit cette année le fait
marquant de 2022 c'est la bourse qui
corrige oui mais c'est le marché
obligataire qui corrige de façon
synchronisée alors la prochaine étape
c'est les taux arrêtent de grimper parce
que l'économie ralentit la bourse encore
quelques quelques mois de volatilité
volatilité prudence de la part du chef
des marchés liquides en parlant de
volatilité exactement fait ça de Lille
merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]